I know you viewers already know this and
Sunday is Mother's Day because you're
smart people so this morning we'd like
to pay tribute to all the moms who will
be honored on Mother's Day it's an
unprecedented moment we're hearing from
new and expectant mothers many in cities
hard-hit by the corona virus they are
all sharing their experiences of
motherhood during this global crisis
along with their wishes their hopes
their dreams for their little ones we
even have a special appearance from our
own Nikki batise so this is my first
Mother's Day ever say hi babies always
we are starting to adapt to real life a
lot of high highs and low lows one of
our favorite places to go is outside and
we are lucky in New York City to have a
balcony this is baby Mia she's five
months old he was born almost two month
ago when you Europe you can episode here
at alpha Kovac 1939 weeks pregnant do
Mother's Day weekend this is our nursery
which is anxiously awaiting the arrival
of our little guy
so she's first of all grown to over her
front teeth
she went from crawling to taking her
first steps which I got to see so one of
the things I do love to do with Sienna
is sing to her
[Music]
dear son you have quite a story to tell
about your journey into this world which
seems fitting because your mom is a
journalist two months before your due
date on Mother's Day weekend the corona
virus pandemic turned our lives upside
down so much of the joy and excitement
pregnancy brings was stripped from your
data me and replaced with fear and
anxiety you won't remember any of this
but believe me when I say that this
isn't what the world is usually like a
lot of time you read this letter the
year you were born
2020 will most certainly be in the
history books just like to offer your
grandparents you were born during a war
a world where friends and family
couldn't hold you for months you would
be stuck inside with mommy and daddy for
days on end and meet people for the
first time wearing masks and gloves you
and I have had to shelter in place for
weeks now mostly on our own your first
fever your first cough was because of
this virus but within a few weeks we
were on the other side I figured I chose
the wrong time to bring you into this
world I cried myself to sleep a number
of nights
fearing the challenges that will be
brought on by the next day what really
made me so sad during those final weeks
you were in my womb was that the only
sound you heard beyond our voices or
sirens to protect your little years from
so much tragedy your dad would play
classical music for you right now you're
too little to understand but life is
beautiful and people are beautiful
we've been sharing your beautiful
moments and
every day like your first dance off to
do away from my dad but I know that in
due time you'll be able to experience
all the things that I have envisioned
for you you'll know what it's like to
keep others needs and well-being before
your own for the sake of our humanity I
hope the one thing you do remember is
the fun we had together though so much
is going to continue to change over the
next few months and years at least we
have each other we want you to remember
the importance of being kind taking care
of yourself the people you love and this
earth life your life in particular is
full of promise thank you for giving me
strength when mine was slipping away it
was an innocent smiles on your faces
that reminded me of the many blessings I
had bestowed upon me and the greatest of
them was you this Mother's Day is gonna
be great I guess my biggest blessing was
born the best happiest day of my life
because you are in it healthy happy and
definitely my best future ahead no
matter what the world ever hands us we
are devoted to protecting you caring for
you and loving you infinitely we
survived the pandemic together baby girl
and it taught us lessons we should never
forget I love you mommy when we love you
to nothing nothing nothing star I was
right nothing stops a mother's love
including a corona virus pandemic we
will all be thinking about Nikki
Batista's weekend thinking about all the
mothers really the job that mothers do
on a daily basis that was very very very
well done